you guys know Moe by now right I mean
you do but let me tell you a little bit
more about them ever since I can
remember
Moe has been the most swag down person
I've ever known we met at 12 years old
in junior high school and even then the
boy knew what to wear and how to wear it
oh look at the vape alley let's go jump
in it you're crazy I just got this
Boracay job super easy did some things
never change please whoa no I'm not
gonna put my sweater down so they took a
walk off with a puddle we're crazy
what about gender equality [ __ ] luxuries
little did we know Moe's little
materialistic ways we're about to take
me for him at the hands of no other than
Kanye West what the Jesus just dropped
can you keep it down trying to watch the
storm special on the Weather Channel
it's done if there is a baby mmm
what's up mischief here with abstract
news heads up the easies are dropping to
night and these are a must-have starting
price is $300 and if you don't get these
you might suck this is silly they're
just shoes these people are going to
stand in line waste their money is so
pointless
alright hey mom well what are you doing
um prepare it to look good about the
globe do you need my computer tonight to
order online huh I'm going down to the
store to wait in line what are you
kidding me tonight's a TV night eat up
you planned it or watch Lu is so-so
he's been planning this for weeks hey
there uh I just wanted to check and see
if I have the friends and family pack I
have a bunch of friends coming over to
watch some TV and no no I know I know I
just wanted to make sure and everything
yeah I told him that's not how friends
or family works look it doesn't matter
I need these sneakers tonight well why
do you need them tonight we have
sneakers right there that you bought
last month all right
these are Yeezy okay and what has kind
of ever done for you
I encourage me to be individual have
artistic value and how to infiltrate the
wealth system in America through
uniqueness okay and you know is my dad
he is nice rocks engages father okay so
that's it you're not coming to see The
Wiz with this thing yeah
oh and by the way you have not paid
right yet but I'm sure these sneakers
are more important I mean you everything
you're in the event you can see it in my
bag
hi my name is Lila you've seen my hand
ring oh my god yo-yo breezy so you're
not going man it's so sad
a hell PW set up a friends and family
yeah you know with us to Sunday 9:00
I'll take it
by the way how do you plan to pay for
these sneakers and for rent I got a
critical you know credit cards aren't
free money right go in pull credit cards
are free money you know that restaurant
for me guys
dude I can't wait to get those Easy's
nobody's touching me girls are going to
be on us you these kids I used to be
just like that yeah yeah me too Loki I'm
still kind of excited okay yeah me too
man just hiding it a little bit
I'm oh man what's your name Keith nice
to meet you and Willie from Philly man
you look real on a one my friends who I
am I work at hex agencies okay y'all
just couple commercials did a couple
times the place for old guys yeah all
right Leo neck yeah you know I'm gonna
get I'm getting but I'm out here oh you
know I mean justice public anything
shavers yeah yeah I actually got working
the morning that you know I'm gonna be a
little bit late but you know how yeah
yeah I do paid my rent yet bro you
should probably pay your rent man happy
easy season man yeah easy
just got the easies
you
you